un appareil de monsieur françois de
mazières merci monsieur le président la
question s'adresse au premier ministre
monsieur le premier ministre la semaine
prochaine devrait être mis au président
notre assemblée le rapport la commission
d' enquête sur les conséquences de la
baisse des dotations d'état aux
collectivités locales
nous attendons bien évidemment que ce
rapport soit rendu public et ne soit pas
enterrée
les français ont le droit de savoir au
moins trois choses premièrement
l'absence de visibilité dans lequel ont
été plongés les élus le gouvernant a agi
trop rapidement trop massivement cette
mesure dont l'effet cumulé sur quatre
ans et de 28 milliards d'euros rien que
ça a été prise sans étude d'impact
la complexité des mécanismes de
distribution mise en place est très
grande et rend le dispositif opaque
voire contraire à la bonne gestion
comment peut-on parler de bonne gestion
quand l'un des paramètres que vous avez
introduit et l'effort fiscal plus le
taux de vos impôts est élevé plus vous
avez droit à la redistribution de
richesses prises sur des communes bien
géré deuxième observation dans cette
incertitude que vous avez créé il ya
hélas une certitude
l'effondrement de l'investissement la
mfc chiffre à 25 pour cent sur trois ans
la baisse du montant des investissements
du bloc communal et c'est ce bloc
communal qui aujourd'hui à 60 % des
investissements publics la conséquence
tout le monde la connaît c'est une
augmentation du chômage
troisième observation le principe de
libre administration des collectivités
locales est aujourd'hui à temps par
l'effet ciseau entre des transferts de
charges non intégralement compensée
évidemment la réforme des rythmes
scolaires le est récent et cette baisse
considérable des dotations les temps
monsieur le premier ministre vous
attirez souvent notre responsabilité
face à la crise nous vous appelons à
votre responsabilité de chef de merci
monsieur de mazières
la parole est à monsieur andré vallini
secrétaire d'état chargé de la réforme
territoriale
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
de mazières votre question relative à la
baisse des dotations de l'état aux
collectivités locales est bien connu
nous en avons débattu souvent dans cet
hémicycle et j'ai moi-même été
auditionnée par la mission parlementaire
à laquelle vous faites référence celle
présidée par monsieur censure cet effort
il est évidemment important personne ne
le conteste
l'état s'affiche à lui-même un effort
plus important encore d'économie de
fonctionnement de baisse des effectifs
et cet effort demandé aux collectivités
locales
il est équitablement réparti grâce à ce
qu'on appelle la péréquation c'est à
dire qu'on demande plus à ceux qui ont
le plus et moins ceux qui sont en
difficulté en renforçant la dotation de
solidarité urbaine et la dotation de
solidarité rurale deuxième élément
monsieur le député la visibilité
vous dites que l'effort n'est pas
visible ni prévisible par les élus
locaux
ces 11 milliards sur trois ans 3
milliards 6 par an tout s'est
parfaitement planifié troisième élément
sur l'investissement monsieur le député
nous sommes très vigilants très soucieux
de l'investissement des collectivités
locales qui représentent 70% de
l'investissement public en france
nous avons renforcé la detr dotation
d'équipement des territoires ruraux et
nous créons un fonds spécial de 1
milliard d'euros destinée à
investissements des communes des
départements et des régions enfin
monsieur le député un dernier élément
les finances locales sont en crise pas
seulement à cause de la baisse des
dotations de l'état
mais parce que cette crise est
structurelle c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous avons lancé la réforme de
la dotation globale de fonctionnement
des réticences des résistances sont
manifestés c'est traitant est remise à
l'année prochaine
je compte sur vous monsieur le député
sur le rapport de la mission sont sus
pour aider le gouvernement à réformer la
dgf et donc les finances locales dans un
sens de plus d'efficacité et de plus de
solidarité
merci monsieur le secrétaire d'état à la
parole et à monsieur roma colas